[Musique]
est ce que vous préparez un recond film
en ile-de-france ile de france est
clairement sur six le nombre de patients
en réanimation dont il faut rappeler que
1 sur 4 décédera je vous rappelle que le
long le qu'ovide l'on toucherait un sur
dix de ses patients on est à quatre
millions de contaminations
ça veut dire que déjà quatre cent mille
français vont avoir auront un qu'ovide
long d'un point de vue sanitaire où il
faudrait être confiné ya aucun doute il
ya aucun doute tant que les les chiffres
sont pattern d'étonner palois m'a fait
ils ne le sont pas on ne peut pas
prendre exactement
nous aurons à prendre dans les jours qui
viennent sans doute de nouvelles
décisions et que nous aurons encore en
prendre
aujourd'hui on est la risée du monde ont
subi une véritable débâcle vaccinale et
cela a évidemment des conséquences à la
fois sur une autre situation sanitaire
et sur la reprise économique
le président de la république qui a
tranché cet après midi au nom du
principe de précaution
la décision qui a été prise en
conformité aussi avec notre politique
européenne
c'est de suspendre par précaution la
vaccination avec astrazeneca
c'est aux autorités sanitaires de
prendre ce type de décision c'est elle
qui savent et je n'y a pas eu de votre
part je visionne je ne m' improvise ray
pas médecin pourtant écoutez bien ce
petit et jean castex dimanche soir je
peux vous assurer qu effectué 20 si
j'avais le moindre doute
si j'avais le moindre vous demanderez la
suze absolument absolument pas ce que
c'est bon de voir c'est ma
responsabilité
c'était la décision à prendre on voit
que tous les pays ont arrêté la campagne
de vaccination avec astrazeneca
donc c'était difficile pour la france de
continuer à elle toute seule pour
maintenir la confiance dans le vaccin on
doit laisser du temps aux expertes et
experts en allemagne et dans l'union
européenne pour se pencher sur les
derniers éléments dont nous disposons
plusieurs pays européens avaient déjà
fait le choix de suspendre totalement ou
partiellement l'administration des
vaccins astrazeneca l'allemagne l'italie
l'espagne et la france ont pris la même
décision aujourd'hui
la liste comprend désormais quinze pays
mais de quelles données dispose-t-on
actuellement au royaume uni on dénombre
35 cas de thrombose sur les 9,7 millions
de personnes vaccinées avec astrazeneca
et quasiment autant 24 chez les 10,7
millions de britanniques vacciner avec
pfizer
il faut aller à toutes les portes sans
faire de l'idéologie savent il ya un
vaccin ruche qui depuis le web le mois
d'octobre et de novembre est réputée par
un des français une commission denquête
qui n'était pas mélenchonistes qui est
allé en russie et qui a dit abel ça
marche à 90% sur toi tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit jean luc
mélenchon en ce sens que les russes ont
commencé à vacciner une partie de leur
population sans qu'on ait toutes les
données mais il n'ya pas d'à priori à
avoir sur ses vaccins mais il faut qu'on
est toutes les données qu'est ce qu'on
dirait si demain ont commencé à vacciner
sans avoir vu toutes les données
évidemment que c'est en train de sens en
train d'être fait madame le pen ne veut
pas du débat à l'assemblée nationale où
je ne la voit jamais elle ne débat pas
monsieur bourdin et quand il est
question de parler de fond la réalité
c'est ça ou rien
oui c'est le délit de fuite l'artiste
said continue son projet monumental
à l'échelle planétaire grande chaîne
humaine
j'ai dit pardonnez moi oui à son propos
voyez qu'elle était une menteuse et
incompétente c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense qu'elle ne veut pas
débattre la différence je l'espère entre
l'été 2021 qui s'annonce et l'été 2020
c'est qu'on aura vaccinés à ce moment là
on retrouvera une partie de notre
liberté
artiste de rue depuis l'enfance save
passe du graffiti au land art
avec l'avènement du trône il change
d'échelle et de points de vue